are we good here
no
hold on i got you you need a sailor can
we just grab one
that's billy eilish stopping her concert
mid-song to check on a fan in the crowd
it all went down on saturday during the
grammy winners happier than ever world
tour stop in atlanta when billy noticed
a concert goer was struggling to breathe
so she paused the show to find out what
was going on are we good here
no
hold on i got you you need a healer
billy made sure that the fan got the
medical attention they needed and kept
the audience calm before continuing the
and hunted right now show all good
everybody's okay
we're gonna keep it going and i want us
all to take a deep breath in here
[Music]
we're taking care of our people thank
you
we love you we love you
billy to be okay
did you catch that last line i'm waiting
for people to be okay
seems like a subtle nod to the travis
scott astro world tragedy back in
november ten fans died and hundreds of
others were injured at the festival in
houston after crowds rushed the stage
during travis's set i'm waiting for
people to be okay
i just want to send out prayers to the
to the ones that was lost i could just
never imagine this radiator situation so
while billy didn't exactly call out the
rapper it seemed to be top of mind for
the oceanized singer
and in the spirit of standing up for
what's right billy did just that last
month when she got fed up with benny
blanco attacking charlie puth on
tick-tock you're a [ __ ] loser booth
look at you you sit in a room all day
and make tick tocks and tell people
dude what the hell's wrong with you look
at your hair it looks like you got a
toupee or a wig on or something get a
grip and get a [ __ ] haircut
yeah billy didn't like that so she made
a video calling out the music producer
what do you do all day buddy
the same thing
literally the same thing that's all i'd
say to be honest with you e.t caught up
with billy back in september at the met
gala where she served as co-chair for
the night and she opened up about the
surreal honor it's
like the most insane honor you would not
believe i feel like i'm in a dream
i feel like i'm like
tripping
and the milestones just keep on coming
which is so incredible and so amazing
billy turned 20 in december and it seems
2022 is already shaping up to be a great
year i'm so excited the song bird is up
for seven grammys in april and if she
wins record of the year again she'll be
the first artist to ever repeat
dude what like i don't even know but win
or lose one thing is for sure billy is
always a winner to us
[Music]